[Music]
what is the relationship between the
remnant and the three angels messages
excellent question if you look at
revelation uh revelation 14 has the
final message for the world verse 6
through 12 of course revelation 18 1-5
is uh is an amplification of the third
angel's message now
after revelation 14 6-12 or down to 13
we have the coming of christ as
represented by
christ sitting on a horse having a
sickle in his hand and a crown on his
head
which means that this the messages of
revelation 14 6-12 are very very
critical they are the messages that
prepare the world to receive christ he
must come back now if you look at the
last part of revelation 14
from verse 14 on we have two harvests
and both are right it is the preaching
of the three angels messages that brings
the world to the point of rightness
either for christ or against him either
way this is the state the world must
reach before jesus come because christ
will not come and put in the sickle
except the harvest is right joel chapter
3 verse 13 puts you in the signal for
the harvest is right mark 4 28 29 when
the harvest is come immediately he put
it in the sickle and so the messages of
revelation 14 6-12 are designed to ripen
the harvest one way or the other
and the remnant are called
to deliver that message boldly even at
the loss of life the same way they
overcame him by the blood of the lamb
and by the word of the testimony and
they love not their lives unto the death
revelation 14 11 the remnant must have
that same attitude we don't care about
our lives we're not reckless but our
lives are not our most precious
possession our precious possession is
truth as it is in jesus the remnant has
been raised up to declare the end time
messages of revelation 14 6-12 which no
other church on the face of the earth
does not even attempt to deliver
that's the purpose of the remnant not
only to preach it but to live it
so the living of it gives power to the
preaching of it
amen amen so we have a work to do as
god's people to give that loud cry
and you know in i was listening to an
another another lecture on the remnant
church and we also see in revelation
chapter 10 how god literally raised up a
people declare
to declare the three angels messages to
the world
and that's clearly stated in the last
verse of revelation 10 that was
prophesied again before people nations
hindus and towns
the prophet saying must go on it did not
end
with uh 1844 has to go on
and it will crescendo in an outcry when
that is preached that's when christ will
come
after that is preached
probation closes the plagues fall christ
comes back
amen amen
so we gotta we gotta work we gotta work
we have to give that loud cry so that
people can come out of
must be babylon priority in our lives i
cannot stress this enough you know titus
1 verse 16 says they profess that they
know god but in works they deny him when
we are we are experts at giving god lip
service but when the rubber hits the
road we are nowhere to be found the the
the preaching of the gospel must become
a priority for us we must find ways to
do it on the job in the streets wherever
it must be this all-consuming priority
so that christ can come back it's not
just we need to do it in words we need
to actually commit our lives to it and
do it even if it means loss of life it
has to be a priority with no challenge
from any other concern
amen that thought comes to mind the
preaching of the gospel is a practical
priority for god's people
amen
you